maybe make your goal a little more smart
so here's an example for example for
example for example in samples in hey
guys I'm a beast right welcome to Abby's
kitchen 2016 was a pretty good year I
got married I started working on my
first cookbook and I celebrated pretty
hard during the holidays hey I'm still
going at it
but even dietitians can overdo it on the
baby quiche and cocktails so if you're
counting on sticking to your try to true
New Year's resolutions in order to get
back on track you may want to rethink
your approach as a dietitian I have seen
them all as a human being I've probably
tried them all so if you're getting
ready to start the annual binge restrict
repent repeat cycle I may have a better
solution introducing our BFF Debbie this
is apparently her year to shine this
smile
Debbie's been making the same year's
resolution every year since she was 14
two days in order for those goals to be
useful and they need to be get ready for
it we're gonna take you back to a little
grated guidance counselor office smart
goals so smart stands for specific
measurable action-oriented realistic and
time-bound let's take a look at how
smarts and the Debbie's goals really are
this is one here to get a week six pack
Oh Debbie apps you not just appear
overnight nor do they pop up after doing
a few sets of crunches in order to get
your abs it's not just about muscle it's
about getting rid of the fat on top of
that muscle there's some pretty extreme
dieting exercise and in all honesty just
having the right jeans for it in other
words getting a six-pack may just not be
very realistic especially without the
checks and balances in place to help you
get there
so if Fitness is your goal and you
actually want to get lean make your goal
smart Earl just a quick little example
here maybe you're gonna swap your daily
Frappuccino for an iced americano
and you're gonna up your weights at the
gym by 10 percent within two weeks or
maybe you're gonna add an extra day at
the gym within the next eight weeks that
is a lot more specific that is a lot
more measurable and that might actually
get you some results this year is all
about eating clean and reading our body
of those
what does clean even mean when people
label individual foods as clean without
taking the entire diet as a whole into
consideration it can be very easy to
slip into not-so-healthy territory and
when I mean unhealthy I mean both
physical and emotional health physical
because of course if you're sitting
around all day eating a ton of clean
food like a ounces and ounces of salmon
all day or like heads and heads of kale
you're probably not going to be doing
too well and emotional I mean we are
seeing the rise in a ton of disordered
eating patterns one of which we call
orthorexia which is at its core clean
eating taking to the extreme so if you
are just eating clean and labeling foods
as good and bad in that way you know
you're setting yourself up for a ton of
guilt shame and body distrust and that
is not healthy having said that if
healthy eating is your goal then make
that goal a little bit more smart for
example instead of just rushing out the
door in the morning and grabbing a
coffee and a doughnut at the local Tim
Hortons do some planning ahead make some
little mason jars with some yogurt and
some berries and granola and just pop
them in the fridge so that they were
ready for breakfast in the morning now
that is something you can sink your
teeth into
this year I don't care what I have to do
I am going to lose some weight
first of all weight is not your best
predictor of health if that's actually
what you're after and second of all you
can hope and wish and pray for weight
loss all you want but unless the
behavioral changes are there I mean
you're never gonna see a budge on the
scale having said that if weight loss is
your goal for whatever reason then at
least make that goal more smart so
instead of focusing so much on the
number on the scale
make some behavioral changes to your
resolution things that you actually have
control over so for example maybe you're
gonna resolve to cut down to two
cocktails in the week and you're gonna
substitute two of your fast food meals
for some homemade soups and salads now
that sounds a lot more doable right Deb
well guys I hope you are now better
equipped to enter the new year with some
smart goals that are more specific
measurable action-oriented realistic and
time-bound rather than flimsy abstract
and let's be honest totally forgettable
so now guys I want to know what kind of
goals have worked well for you in the
past
what are your SMART goals what are not
working so well leave me a comment below
I totally want to get your take on this
also give this video the thumbs up if
you liked it subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you in the new year on
Abby's kitchen
you
[Music]